The general good experience. Yeah,
and the justice system is obviously
that's a really interesting thing to talk
about and constitutional law is a
fascinating thing for people studying this
idea that we argue about
the second amendment,
like let's let constitutional lawyers
that think discuss a lot of those things
and we should all understand
that and be curious about it.
But I would think our constitution is
also silly. Like let's remake everything.
Like let's have that conversation was
so much better that we can do have a
serious conversation about what kind
of guns and bullets people can have.
Not that they can have them
or that they can't have.
Like that's the conversation. That's
where we should be. Right now.
Everything gets regulated. Everything.
There are trade offs and healthcare,
there are trade offs and everything,
but Americans now are so divided.
They want everything that they want.
That compromise is something that we
don't do as Americans much less in in
government. That's, that's preposterous.
That the Democrats that demand purity
or, or anybody that is doing that,
you don't agree with me, you're wrong.
Hold on. That's not not you're related.
You don't have any relationships with
people in your real life like that.
Like my wife and I don't agree on
a lot of stuff, but I love her.
I adore her. Well, it's what
we've talked about before.
They're on teams and you want your
team to win, so you state why?
Why do you want your team to win? It's a
natural thing with human beings, right?
I agree that what I'm
saying about the gun thing,
the most fucked up part about
the messiness of the gun
thing is that even if you
made guns illegal, even if you
said you can't have any bullets,
you'll all go to jail. There's so many
guns. You're not getting them all.
It's not possible. There's
more guns in there are people,
which means there's more than 300 and
what 30 million guns there are country
alone. Absolutely. The most
important point in the discussion.
That's a nutty number, man. You really
stop and think about that number.
You're like, what is that real?
But you don't really stop the behavior
by necessarily creating certain laws
about why someone might behave
a certain way and shoot people.
That's not going to necessarily change.
What you do is you do limit the access
to a certain types of weapons and rounds
of ammunition. Right?
Yeah. Well the real question is
why would someone do that? Right?
That's the number one
question. [inaudible] let's
say the hardest part truck,
but it's a harder question to answer.
The easier question to answer is
make them less accessible. Yes.
If you've got people who have
problems we can figure out or solve,
if you could make them less accessible,
the president or blame, like,
I don't mean to get political,
but like there's no data on the video
game argument that there's no data on it.
The on
that. Well,
the video game argument is interesting
because I've had soldiers bring it up to
me, including Dakota Meyer.
Yeah, I heard that conversation.
I'm willing to have it. I mean I don't,
I don't think it necessarily makes sense
that people would act out in a certain
way that's horrific because of video game.
But if they were already
inclined to violence,
begin with maybe the already had a
fucking short circuit and then they get
desensitized to violence in movies
and violence and video games.
Does that have an impact on them? I'm
not the guy to answer that question.
[inaudible] has an impact
on, it's a variable.
It's a variable that I
think merits discussion.
I don't know if it's true or not.
I don't think it is because I
don't think it merits discussion.
Well, let me make this
point and then you decide.
If you think of merits discussion. Okay.
The V violent video games are played at
far higher rates in Japan and they don't
have the gun violence. We
have. It's a good point.
They have a very different culture though.
The way they don't have access
to guns. That's true. That's it.
They don't also have a lot of,
they've had a few mass stabbings.
It's the access. I, dude, I've
shot guns. I shoot guns, I get the,
I, I have nothing but respect for hunters.
I grew up in a hunting community. Uh,
but I mean, I, I don't know.
I don't think that there's much
past the conversation about access,
accessibility to guns that can fire that
many rounds that quickly killing that
many people. I don't think we have to
get rid of those somehow. But I agree.
How do you do it? Your, that's the most
important point. There's already 330.
There's more guns than there are people.
So what do you do? So by the way,
I think you buy as many
as you can back for sure.
You spend a whole bunch of taxpayer
money just help. By the way,
there's a ton of people in a bind
right now that have a rifle of like,
Oh my God, I'm not gonna be able to
afford my insulin. Let me get rid of this.
Uh, AK 47 to live another
month. You buy some guns back.
It's a good expenditure of money and
then melt them down and turn them into
furniture for a people.
So if you wanted to do that without
changing the second amendment,
like you just have a,
a buyback where you just offer people
the opportunity to make some money by
giving their guns up.
Well,
the second amendment is been interpreted
wrong by the Supreme court in my
opinion.
I mean it doesn't say that people should
have until 2008 it didn't say that.
Nobody thought that that people should
have a personal right to guns till the
Heller case.
But so I don't think you even need
to talk about the second amendment.
I think just people just need to agree
that these guns shouldn't be sold at the
ammunition to talk about the
second amendment. I mean it's,
it's a big conversation as people
can have guns, you can have guns.
The brick has a right to have guns.
You just can't have these guns anymore.
No more of those ones. You can have all
these guns, no restrictions anywhere.
Right. And they work city. You can't
have a handgun. Yeah, they work.
You can't even, I don't
think you can have a, a,
you can have a switch plate in New
York city. Yeah. Cyrus Vance, the da.
There is like terrified that they're
changing the federal government's changing
the law because he knows that those
gun laws in New York work really well.
And by the way, people always
make the argument, well,
they have those gun laws in Chicago
and there's a ton of violence.
That's because Chicago's on the
board of Indiana, doesn't have them.
Guns go across the border just
fine. That's the gun laws work.
They work well. Chicago is also in the
middle of of bitter drug war. Well, yeah.
I mean that's where the finals
is coming from, but we should,
people should have less
accessibility to those
types of guns, like every other
civil society in the world. Come on,
this is like, but it goes back to
what you were talking about before,
like the drugs, if they were legal, you
wouldn't have that sort of a drug war.
Right? For sure.
It's the root of most of the violence
in the inner cities and in obviously in
Mexico. Yeah, it's the, it's black
markets. It's the illicit drug. Yeah.
They're making tons of money on that.
What is the second amendment
exactly as it's written? Can you,
the right to bear arms
shall not be infringed.
So how do you think that the
Supreme court misinterpreted that?
That in the in the 2008 Alec
case, everybody should just a,
I would plug the work of Eric
Siegel who is well regulated,
militia being necessary to the security
of a free state comma right of the
people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed. Yeah.
Those commons get argued by,
I know constitutional scholars for a
date that the Supreme court didn't decide
until 2008 that Americans had a
right to have their own weapon.
That's such a crazy statement
like when you read it,
it's so interesting because you were going
back in time trying to figure out how
people in 1776 thought about guns and
whether or not that applies to us because
if it doesn't apply to us we
have to think about 1789 we,
if it doesn't apply to us, we have to
think, well then who gets to decide?
Like one of the reasons you get to decide
as a society on on any of one of the
reasons why it's so
interesting. I want to believe.
One of the reasons why it's so interesting
to read these things is like we have,
for whatever reason,
when things get written written
into stone or carved into a,
a stone or written onto a
document, like the first amendment,
like the freedom of expression,
we that is that we, we have it.
So we all agree on it. We don't want
to change it. Yeah. Freedom of speech,
freedom of expression, whatever we
want to, we want to hold on to that.
We want to keep sure I, this is
our humans, the second amendment,
the right to have a gun. That's our
law. We got it written down. Look, look,
look. It's written there. So they'll
study these ancient words like scrolls,
like to go over these scrolls and look
at the commas and look at the words shall
not be infringed upon. What did they
mean? That's fascinating. It is.
It is fascinating. But I think
that they didn't mean this.
I think that how could they, they did
not know what this is. They didn't,
and the the, the whole gun thing is a
racket to make money. That's what that is.
It's, it's a way you
sell fear. Like are you,
I mean home invasion is
any family's worst fear,
but it doesn't happen very much.
Nor does kidnapping nor do all lot of
these crimes at all. My helicopter,
our generation of parents is helicopter
parents terrified of everything.
Not that's true. That's true. Letting
their kids go outside. You're right.
Come on thinking that your kid's going
to get kidnapped. You don't know anybody.
Okay. Who had their
kid kidnapped. You are,
but you're generalizing because
home invasions do happen sometimes,
but that's not how we shouldn't make
the laws, but we don't have to exist.
Like everybody's going to kidnap
your kid or everyone's going
to break into your home.
But I'm saying those kinds of
balance is that sometimes it's real.
That's why people want to be able to
have guns because sometimes someone can
break in your house and
people have defended their
house and their property with
guns. Sure. But it's, it's, is it a way,
is it a realistic threat or
is it something that the,
that the gun industry creates these
amazing ads and scares the shit out of
people? Oh, come on man.
It's crime is real. You know,
whether the crime is
real crime. Real, real.
I think the clear point is,
the reason why we have so many guns in
America is because there's so much money
to be made off of them.
I think we could absolutely limit them
and regulate them and have a thoughtful
conversation. I think that's
where most most people are at.
Although I hate that generalization.
There's something to that,
but there's also something to, the reason
why we have so many cars. People like,
I'll have that conversation. We should
get rid of all the cars. Okay, well,
I mean we're not looking me wrong.
Why should we get rid of all the cars?
Do not like freedom or do you
want, you have a better solution?
Are you going to, I don't have a
better solution, but if they're there,
there should to be one or I think that
we are killing ourselves with all the
cars. The pollution is okay, but you can
make them electric then. That's fine.
I think that would be fine if they were,
I have a Chevy volt since
2012 I have solar panels.
I'm trying to be the change
I want to see in the world.
If I'm coming off as a act, I'm a
complete hypocrite and all of it.
I eat meat and I do all kinds of things.
I think have a thoughtful conversation
about guns and why they're each part of
our culture and not another culture.
The way that other cultures and
countries regulate their weapons,
that the problems that they
have. Our problem shore,
we should talk about mental health,
but the problem with that conversation
that people don't want to have is
everything costs money. That's
why you have to pay taxes.
Paying taxes is the price of civilization.
What does that have to
do with mental health?
You have to pay for people
to help people, right?
You can't advocate in government,
Republican or Democrat for the,
this is what unfortunately Trump
and Republicans have advocated,
let's get mental health
solutions to the violence.
Let's do that and everybody's behind that
except they cut the Obamacare programs
at funded mental health.
It's just you can't do,
you have to spend the money providing
mental health. It is a problem.
It should be addressed, but it's not.
The main issue is definitely the
guns and the bullets in them. Well,
the main issue is the person
that's capable of shooting
people with the guns and
the bullets know it's the guns and
the guns and the bullets are inanimate
objects. Without a person pulling the
trigger. We're talking nonsense here.
They're not going to
just shoot themselves.
The main problem is the main problem
is someone willing to grab the gun and
shoot people. Right. We agreed.
We both agree there's
problems with having no idea,
but don't you think the main problem
is the person who actually shoots me?
I think that in every
other country in the world,
they don't have this problem
because they don't have the gun.
That's my where I start and end on
the argument. Okay. Why? Why is that?
They might, they might.
That might be the case
that they don't have the guns,
but there are places that do have
guns and they don't have a lot of mass
shootings. Canada's one of them.
Right, because they don't know.
They don't have the type of guns we
have up there. Have a lot of guns.
They do, but they don't have AK
40 sevens with unlimited rounds.
They don't have that. That's
crazy. If you have more guns,
they're awesome. I get it.
Okay.
Do you think that more or less limitations
to what firearms are allowed to have?
I believe they Canada.
I believe that Canada, Canadian gun
laws are far stronger, more regulated,
tried. They don't have
something. Some, some really,
recently Trudeau announced something
that was going to severely limit,
this is very recent, severely limit
the type of firearms you could have,
including things that can have multiple
rounds and chambers and certain types of
guns that are used right
now as hunting rifles.
Since there was a big push back about
that. Let's just read. There's always,
there's always going to find that
the conversation about like,
like the the freedom, like the,
the second amendment to me is it's
just your interpretation. Fine.
Whatever your interpretation is is
fine. That's what's interesting.
There's a human insight. It's a
healthcare issue and they and they the,
it's so extreme. It's really,
if you want to know the
answer to healthcare is you
should talk to public health
experts. They have those
answers. They have the research,
but we'll hold on what
research on what? Well,
they don't have enough research on.
They don't have enough research
on gun violence. Unfortunately.
I'm talking about if you want to know
the solutions for what is impacting and
creating a death by any measure.
Accidental death. Right,
but we're talking about
gun violence, right?
Healthcare professionals have
the solutions to gun violence.
I think a lot of healthcare
solutions, I think,
I think certainly surgeons have argued
for why certain ammunition has destroying
the inside of the body and unsurvivable.
I think public health
officials have argued,
certainly pediatricians all argued this
idea that you can't ask a parent if they
have a gun in the house because the
gun lobby is against that cause they're
building this conspiracy that the
government is going to track your gun.
That's terrible. Your pediatrician
has to ask you, do you have a pool?
Where do you keep the poison? Where are
the guns? Cause God forbid you don't,
you're not responsible enough or educated
enough to know that that kid might
accidentally get that gun.
And it happens all the time.
There's a rule against that. Yeah.
Public health officials and doctors and
physicians are pretty much on the same
case with this issue, these guns and
mental health. I think experts too,
I don't know, maybe there's a
large disagreement and if there is,
I'm happy to be wrong about this
or any dumb shit. I've said,
well,
what you're saying is that these public
health officials would be able to make
these guns less lethal by banning
certain types of ammunition because it's
destroying people and checking
to see if the parents uh,
know if they have a gun or where
the gun is or how it's treated,
how it's locked up like that
they should, I mean, how,
how do you feel like public officials,
public health officials could
have any impact on that? Well,
public health experts are, you know,
their entire sponsor ability to keep
people safe from sickness and death.
Look, if you have any bullets
at all, they're lethal, right?
So do you want to have
bullets that are less lethal?
I think that could be a law for
sure. Why not us lethal? Yeah.
Take two human bodies. Yeah.
We shouldn't be killing each other
with bullets all the time. A bullet,
I'll stop anybody a
blunt or whatever it is.
I don't understand the arguments about
ammunition, but the point about Poe,
but you brought it up. That's
why I brought it up. Fine.
Public health experts will look at
what is creating sickness and death car
accidents.
What I'm saying to you is that I think
it's disingenuous to say that public
health officials have an answer to why
we're having so much mass violence.
I don't think anybody has an
answer. I think we're terrified.
And I think we could say it's,
if they didn't have guns,
he wouldn't be able to do it. And
you're right. And I can say if we,
these people weren't mentally
handicapped or filled with,
I shouldn't say handicapped melted
me mentally compromised, uh,
filled with all kinds of
demons, all sense of demons,
the different medications that are
fucking with their judgment, uh, abuse,
all sorts of, of they spirits and
childhood. There's a lot of factors. Sure.
No one,
no one has any idea why someone who is
abused and who's fucked up is capable of
making that leap. We have some
thoughts on it. That's all.
We have some thoughts on it and we talk
about it endlessly. And you're right,
if no one had a gun, there
would be no issue with that.
You wouldn't be able to mass shoot people.
But would we still have fucked up people
that are lashing out trying to hurt
people. I think we always will, but we
have mental health. We have to fund.
No one's already searched. Yeah. A
lot of people are, well, I'm not.
I think you should. I think we
should, not only should we comp
[inaudible] mental health, we,
it should be a top priority.
I think we should think about having
four hour work days being mandatory.
I think we should help
people. I think you, you know,
they just did an experiment
Microsoft did in Japan in fact,
and they found that a four hour or
a four day work week rather increase
productivity by 40% yeah. I think
a lot of people, I don't know,
maybe this is their culture or maybe
it was, this is a specific instance,
the type of people that would get a
job at Microsoft, but you know what?
What you're dealing with for most people
is beaten down shells that are tired of
high. All that together. Go
back to the gun argument.
Argue for the four hour work week in any
other type of benefits that civilized
nations around the world,
especially in Scandinavia,
have study in that culture is really
interesting and what they do and,
and you realize that there's any number
of things that you can do to help people
and how do you,
you have to be able to fund those
solutions and people don't want to do it,
right? People don't
want to pay more taxes,
but they also have a distrust in the
way the government spends their money.
So it becomes a catch 22 even if
they wanted things to be better,
they don't trust the government
to spend their money.
Like if you work hard and you make X
amount of dollars and the government
argument, but there's not a bet
necessarily a better way, fine,
I give you that argument,
but there we have to come
together as society and gray.
This is how we're going to spend
money on a fire department,
on schools and so on.
Well, no one's arguing
[inaudible].